heightened security near baghdad's green
zone it comes after the prime minister's
residence in the fortified area came
under attack
the government says three armored drones
were flown over the compound of mustafa
al-khazami
one hit the building two others were
shut down
to all of those who were worried my
residence was targeted in a cowardly
attack
thanks to god and his grace all of those
working with me and i are doing well
these cowardly rockets and these
cowardly drones do not help in building
nations nor can they be part of any
future
the government said it's investigating
the incident
the u.s state department has offered to
help
in iran the secretary of the supreme
national security council called it a
terrorist attack
he blamed for an intervention for what
he described as new sedition
the attack came two days after
demonstrations against the results of
parliamentary elections in october left
at least one person dead and many
injured
pro-iranian parties lost about
two-thirds of their seats in the vote
they've accused the electoral commission
of rigging the results and demand
recount
many of their supporters are members of
the popular mobilization forces
the party's military wings
they've since occupied areas near the
heavy fortified green zone
that's home to international diplomatic
missions and government offices
pro-iranian groups are among the
demonstrators here but these protesters
deny they carried out the attack and say
it may have been orchestrated by a third
party to ferment violence between them
and security forces
pro-iranian armoured groups have been
accused of carrying out similar drone
attacks over the past two years against
u.s military bases and facilities in the
green zone
some protesters said the drone attack
targeted them and the government
there are evil people behind it who want
to create chaos and divert the public's
attention away from the main cause
demanding justice for those who were
killed on friday and stir animosity
between the government and the popular
mobilization force
some of these protesters are skeptical
they say the attack was fake and accuse
el khazemi of pretending to be a victim
they're vowing to continue their
demonstration
al jazeera
baghdad